Hi everyone!
Thanks for tuning in to
our third and final video on this English Online
Business English series for building resilience.
Let’s take a look at our third tip.
This is something that might sound like
a little bit of a cliché, but it is much
harder to put into practice than you might
think, and that is being kind to yourself.
I know for me, I am my own harshest critic.
I always set the bar for myself way higher than I
would expect anyone else in my position to achieve
or to reach and I know I’m not the only one.
Being kind to yourself is not only
about reducing our negative self-talk,
but is also about taking care of
ourselves both physically and mentally.
Let’s take a look at five tips
that you could apply to your life
over the next few weeks, and see if it
makes a difference to your resilience.
Our first tip might seem like a little bit of an
easy one, but trust me, it makes a big difference.
If you don’t already, you should
start making your bed in the morning.
Making our bed in the morning really sets us up
for the day and makes us feel like, that we’ve
already achieved something, even though it’s
super small, and it helps you to feel prepared.
Our second tip is about exercise.
I know this isn’t always possible,
so you could also think of it
this way. The two-minute rule.
If I’m lacking in energy, feeling down, or
just not in the mood, do it for two minutes.
The chances are, once you’ve started, you will do
it for a little bit longer than the two minutes.
And, if you’ve started, you’ve done your two
minutes and you really can’t be bothered to
keep going, then don’t, stop. You did
it for two minutes, try again tomorrow.
Our third tip is to avoid toxic positivity.
Recently, there has been a huge growth in the area
of self-care and mindfulness which is amazing,
but don’t forget that it is also okay to
have a bad day, or to be in a terrible mood.
You don’t have to be positive
and happy all the time.
Our next tip, don’t forget to take stock of
all the things that you have actually achieved.
Recently I had a conversation with a friend
of mine who was feeling a little bit down.
She was talking about some new
colleagues that she had met,
and how amazing they were, and started
listing off all of their great achievements.
The things on the list that I heard
her talk about, she had also achieved.
Whether it’s on a day to day, week to week,
or even just take the opportunity once a
month to remind yourself of all of the things,
over the course of your life
that you have done. And be proud.
Our last tip today is to take a moment to
yourself and do something that you enjoy.
For me, one of my biggest joys is taking a
couple of minutes just to drink a chai latte.
It doesn’t matter where I am. Taking that
couple of minutes to enjoy that hot drink,
even the smell of it right now is
making me feel relaxed calm and happy.
There you go guys, that is our final tip
on building resilience, and there are five
different activities there that you can try to
implement over the next couple of weeks
and see if it makes a difference to you.
If you want to catch up with some of the other
series with things like conflict management,
or tips for interviewing then please
take a look and click on the link
you can see here.
I’ll see you next time!